if you're a wild horse summer at the
prior mountain wild horse reserve on the
Montana Wyoming border is as close to
heaven as you're going to find here on
earth
withers can be harsh but summer pastures
are emerald blankets of eminently edible
greenery
and if you're a mature male with your
own harem life is full of rainbows now
most of the time
these wild horses have two social groups
the first is what's called a harem
social system here several mares and
their foals are guarded by a single
dominant male this dominant male is 10
years old he chances upon a pile of
droppings called a stud pile this tells
him that the other social group is
nearby and that it's time for him to
take action the other social group is
this band of young bachelor stallions
each looking to establish its own harem
the dominant male moves his harem to a
safe distance
then he makes his move on the intruders
even though he's outnumbered
he's got the advantages of age and
experience his band stays put on the
sidelines then the dominant male kicks
but his aim is to assert Authority not
hurt anyone
according to the ancient texts the art
of war a great warrior radiates strength
he doesn't have to fight to the death
and neither does this male the rogue
stallions move on and life is once again
fresh grass and rainbows